عاش العالم حربين عالميتين من قبل
، ذاق فيهما البشر أشد أنواع العذاب والمعاناة،
قتل فيهما العشرات والعشرات من الملايين،
أكل الناس أوراق الأشجار،
تم إنهاء مظاهر الحياة في بعض الدول،
وبعض المدن تم محوها من الخارطة،
هيروشيما وناغازاكي قنبلتان نوويتان
لا زالت آثارهما إلى الآن
وقد مر عليهما أكثر من ٧٠ عام،
الضحايا من الروس والألمان والأمريكان
والغرب والعالم أجمع،
دخلت الحرب إلى كل منزل
وجابت النيران اليابسة بأكملها،
واليوم الجميع يتحدث عن حرب عالمية ثالثة،
فهل يعود الناس إلى السيف والرمح والخيل،
فسلاح الدول اليوم يكفي ليمحو
الكرة الأرضية بأسرها من المجموعة الشمسية،
فعن أي حرب نتحدث يا سادة؟
وماذا سيحدث للبشر وكيف سيصبح العالم
إن قامت هذه الحرب يا ترى؟
....روسيا، الصين، كوريا الشمالية،
إيران، والجزائر، في حلف واحد
ومن سينضم إليهم بعدها...
أمريكا، بريطانيا، فرنسا، جميع الدول الأوروبية،
إسرائيل، اليابان، تايوان وكوريا الجنوبية،
ومن سينضم إليهم حينها.
سيتغير لون الكرة الأرضية إلى اللون الأحمر،
وستسقى الأشجار بالدماء،
وسيصبح سعر الحيوان أغلى من سعر الإنسان،..
الغواصات النووية الدمار الشامل،
قنبلة كيم لإنهاء التكنولوجيا،
أسلحة الشيطان الروسي
وسلاح الشمس الحارقة،
السلاح الأمريكي الذي يصنف بأنه الأقوى،
القنابل النووية المدمرة للكثير من الدول،
وبعد هذا كله، نسأل ماذا سيحدث "
في الحرب العالمية الثالثة "؟
إليكم أدق التوقعات .!!
كما هي عادات الحروب فسينقسم العالم إلى جانبين،
ولن يكون هناك دول محايدة بحسب التوقعات،
والقاعدة يومها ستكون
(من لم يكن معي فهو ضدي)
وعلى هذا الأساس ستنقسم الدول بين
حليف لهذا الطرف وحليف للطرف آخر...
(الجانب الأول)
حلف روسيا..
دول منظمة معاهدة الأمن الجماعي..
في عام 1992 قامت 6 دول سوفييتة
سابقة تنتمي إلى رابطة الدول المستقلة
(روسيا، أرمينيا، كازاخستان، طاجيكستان،
قيرغيزستان، وأوزباكستان)
بالتوقيع على المعاهدة الأمنية الجماعية
(تعرف أيضا بـ"حلف طشقند" أو "معاهدة طشقند").
فنزويلا، كوبا، نيكاراغوا، سوريا، كوريا الشمالية
الديمقراطية ٥دول ستكون حليفة
ليس من أجل المال بل كرها في سياسات
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية، ،،
ويمكن إضافة أفغانستان إلى القائمة،
فهي لا زالت تعاني من العبث الأمريكي
في أراضيها والذي دام لعشرين عام.....
جميع هذه الدول لديها علاقات غير جيدة
مع الولايات المتحدة، لأنها لا تريد أن تعيش
تحت إملاء "الديمقراطية الغربية"
بالإضافة إلى ذلك،
في حال طلبت روسيا، ستقوم كل من كوبا
ونيكاراغوا بإرسال قواتها إلى أفريقيا أو فنزويلا.
أو على العكس من ذلك، يمكن أن ترسل فنزويلا
قواتها إلى كوبا. وهذا السيناريو كان موجودا
في عهد الاتحاد السوفيتي،
عندما دافعت القوات الكوبية عن الثورات
في أنغولا وإثيوبيا.
بينما القوات السورية يمكن أن تقدم مساعدة
في العراق أو ليبيا في حال الحاجة لذلك.
ومن هنا يمكننا أن نرى أن روسيا تمتلك
5 حلفاء جاهزين للمساعدة العسكرية
في حال لزم الأمر ذلك....
يعتبر مجنون كوريا الشمالية كيم جونغ أون
أحد أقوى الحلفاء لروسيا،
بجانب أنه عدو صريح لأمريكا
يتحين الفرصة المناسبة ليطلق قنبلته النووية
التي تدعى (النبضة الكهرومغناطيسية)،
وإن أطلق المجنون قنبلته فلن تكون إلا على
أمريكا العدو اللدود للمجنون،
مما سيؤدي إلى إنهاء التكنولوجيا والكهرباء
في الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية،
لكن ماذا عن بقية حلفائها أيها المجنون؟
الصين إحدى أقوى وأعظم الدول في العالم،
في الصناعة العسكرية هي في المراتب الأولى
وعدد سكانها يعادل قارات بأكملها،
يعرف الجميع بوجود قرابة ٣٠٠ قنبلة نووية
تمتلكها الصين، فيما تقول بعض التقارير
أن الصين تمتلك قرابة ٥٠٠٠ قنبلة نووية
أي ما يعادل العدد الذي تمتلكه أمريكا
من هذه القنابل، وسواء أكان العدد صحيحا
أم لا فالصين هي الدولة المتوقعة أن تحكم العالم
وفقا لبعض الخبراء العالميين،،،
وقوة أصحاب العيون الضيقة ستكون بجانب
روسيا لا محالة في حال قامت الحرب المتوقعة..
إيران الدولة الإسلامية النووية..
كثفت أمريكا عقوباتها على إيران،
لكنها ظلت صامدة،
وكانت روسيا معارضة لتلك العقوبات،
وبما أن إيران تعمل ليل نهار
على برنامجها النووي،
فهي قوة كبيرة ستضاف إلى الحلف الروسي، .
.وهي فرصة أيضا لتنتقم إيران
من الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية...
على قائمة حلفاء روسيا يوجد أيضا الجزائر
التي تستورد سلاحها بمئات ملايين الدولارات
من موسكو، وتعتبر الجزائر وهي أكبر دولة عربية
مساحة أحد الحلفاء الذين يتوقع
أن ينضموا للحلف الروسي،  ....
كما يمكن أن تنضم العراق إلى هذا الحلف
بعد أن قتلت أمريكا أكثر من مليون عراقي
خلال احتلالها لبلد صدام،،
وهناك أم الدنيا مصر التي تستورد حبوبها
من روسيا وهي على علاقة جيدة بالروس،،
وهناك أيضا الشيشان التي أرسلت مقاتليها
إلى جانب القوات الروسية في أوكرانيا..
ولا ننسى أيضا أرمينيا، وبيلاروسيا
التي تعتبر من أبرز حلفاء موسكو، كازاخستان،
قيرغيزستان، طاجيكستان،
وهي دول موالية لروسيا.
وقد تطول قائمة الحلف الروسي الكثير من الدول
الكارهة لأمريكا.  ويبقى أن نذكر
أن هذا الحلف سيكون بقيادة الدب الروسي
الذي سيكون في مقدمة الحلف
إن قامت الحرب العالمية الثالثة كما هو متوقع..
ويكفي أن نذكر أن روسيا تمتلك من الأسلحة
ما يكفي لتدمير العالم وليس لتدمير أمريكا فقط
فهناك صواريخ الشيطان وهناك قاذفات اللهب
(سلاح الشمس الحارقة) وهناك أكثر
من ٦٠٠٠ قنبلة نووية...
فهل لا زلنا نتحدث عن وجود للعالم
بعد أن تقرع طبول هذه الحرب العالمية المتوقعة...
(الجانب الثاني)
حلف أمريكا
حلف شمال الأطلسي
يشكل حلف الناتو نظاما للدفاع الجماعي
تتفق فيه الدول الأعضاء على الدفاع المتبادل
رداً على أي هجوم من قبل أطراف خارجية.
ثلاثة من أعضاء الناتو
(الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية وفرنسا والمملكة المتحدة)
هم أعضاء دائمون في مجلس الأمن الدولي
يتمتعون بـ حق الفيتو وهم رسميا دول حائزة
للأسلحة النووية. ويقع المقر الرئيسي لحلف الناتو
في هارين، بروكسل، بلجيكا،
في حين أن مقر عمليات قيادة حلف الناتو
يقع بالقرب من مونس، بلجيكا.
يتكون هذا الحلف من ٣٠ دولة ومنها
دول تعتبر ضمن الدول الأقوى في العالم
فبخلاف (أمريكا وفرنسا وبريطانيا)
هناك (ألمانيا، تركيا، كندا، إسبانيا، البرتغال، بلجيكا)
والقائمة تطول ....
بريطانيا  في المرتبة الثامنة لأقوى الجيوش عالميا،
إلا أنها عضو في حلف شمال الأطلسي (الناتو)
الذي يعد التجمع العسكري الأقوى في العالم.
وتمتلك بريطانيا 280 رأسا نوويا.
وبعد خروجها من الاتحاد الأوروبي
جعلت بريطانيا روسيا هي عدوها الأول،
لتكون بذلك أبرز الحلفاء لأمريكا
في حال قامت الحرب المتوقعة...
تشكل فرنسا واحدة من الدول النووية الخمس
، كما أن سلاح البحرية الفرنسي حصل مؤخرا
على فرقاطة قتالية متطورة.
وعلى عكس السفن التي سبقتها من نفس النوع
لم يركز صانعوها على جعلها مضادة للغواصات،
بل طوروها لتعمل بشكل فعال على مكافحة
الأهداف الجوية المعادية..
في هذا الحلف هناك تركيا أيضا
التى وعلى الرغم من أنها معاقبة في تصنيع السلاح
إلا أنها تعد إحدى أقوى الدول في العالم،
وتمتلك أحدث الطائرات المسيرة المعروفة
ببيرقدار ويتم استخدام هذه الطائرات
في الحرب الروسية الأوكرانية،
وقد أثبتت كفاءتها من قبل في عمليات مشابهة...
الجيش الألماني الذي لم يعد بقوته التي أرعبت
العالم مع هيتلر يوما ما،
ولكنه أحد أقوى الجيوش في العالم،
سينضم هذا الجيش بعدته وعتاده إلى الحلف الأمريكي..
الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
هي الدولة التي تتحكم بأكبر عدد من الدول
حول العالم، وتأتي دولة الهند من ضمن الحلفاء
الأقوياء لأمريكا في العالم،
حيث يصل عدد السكان إلى أكثر من مليار نسمة
مع توقعات أن تتجاوز الهند الصين
وتصبح الدولة الأكثر في عدد السكان في العالم
بأكثر من مليار ونصف خلال السنوات المقبلة،،
وتمتلك الهند رابع أقوى جيش في العالم
بقرابة ٥ملايين جندي في قواتها المسلحة،
الكثير من الدول ستدخل في حلف أمريكا
البعض منها هي حليف دائم كدول حلف الناتو ال٣٠،
والتي تشكل أقوى تحالف عسكري في العالم،
ودول أخرى ستدخل رغما عنها بضغط أمريكي،
ودول أخرى ترى أن هذا الحلف هو الأقوى
فستنضم طواعية، ،  كل هذه الدول بسلاحها
وجيوشها ومالها ستنضم في الجانب الأمريكي
الذي سيكون قائدا لهذا الطرف،،
ويبقى أيضا أن نذكر أن الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
تمتلك أقوى الجيوش في العالم بحسب التصنيف العالمي،
وتمتلك أكثر من ٥٠٠٠رأس نووي،
وأقوى أسلحة الجو وأقوى أنظمة الدفاع،
وأقوى البارجات، كل هذا سيكون في الحلف الأمريكي
لقتال الطرف الآخر بقيادة روسيا،،
وهو ما ينذر بحرب شاملة لن يبقى فيها شجر ولا حجر،،
ولربما تنتهي البشرية الحالية مع التكنولوجيا
ونعود بالزمن آلاف السنين إلى الوراء...
(دول غير واضحة المعالم)
أكثر من مئتي دولة حول العالم
ستنقسم بين الحلف الأمريكي والحلف الروسي
ولكن قد يزيد عدد الحلفاء في طرف عن الطرف الآخر
وزيادة عدد الحلفاء لا يعني أن هذا الطرف
سيكون أقوى من الآخر بالضرورة،،،
بينما بعض الدول لربما تظل محايدة،
والدولة التي لن تدخل الحرب ستكون ساحة للقتال،
لما تتميز به من ثروات أو لموقها المتميز،،
فهناك اليمن التي يقع فيها مضيق باب المندب
والذي يعد أحد أهم المضائق البحرية للتجارة العالمية
ولمرور السفن الحربية إن قامت الحرب،،
(دول الخليج)
ملوك النفط، رفض أمراء الخليج بقيادة السعودية
والإمارات مطالبات عديدة من الولايات المتحدة الأمريكية
المشاركة في خفض أسعار النفط لمواجهة غزو روسيا
لأوكرانيا،، ورفض الخليج بذلك
أن يكون طرفا عالقا بين مطرقة أمريكا وسندان روسيا...
من جهتها أعلنت أمريكا رسميا أن قطر
حليف استراتيجي من خارج حلف الناتو،..
لكن قطر لم تقرر بعد إن كانت ستنضم إلى حلف أمريكا
أم لا.. لتظل محايدة على الأقل في الوقت الراهن
فيما لو قامت الحرب الملعونة..
فسيخسر جميع الأطراف بدون شك،
تعرف الحرب بأنها ستكون حربا عالمية ثالثة،
لكنها لن تكون كسابقتيها، فبعد الحربين العالميتين
الأولى والثانية بدأ العالم بالتقدم والتطور
حتى وصلت التكنولوجيا إلى مستوى عالٍ جدا،
لكن إن قامت هذه الحرب فستنهي التكنولوجيا لا محالة،
وسيعود العالم إلى الخيل والسيف،
بل وسيفنى مئات الملايين من البشر نتيجة لهذه الحرب،
وسيتم تسوية المدن بالتراب، والأسوأ سيأتي بعد ذلك...
هذا فقط هو الجزء الأول لما هو متوقع
إن اشتعلت الحرب العالمية الثالثة
وفي الجزء الثاني سنذكر لكم أبرز الأحداث
التي قد تحدث حينها...
فهل يتجنب العالم حربا عالمية ثالثة؟
خصوصا وأن الجميع يعرفون عواقب هذه الحرب؟
أم أن الدول ستدخل الحرب عنوة مجازفين بكل المخاطر؟
وأنتم متابعينا ما الذي تتوقعونه في وضع كهذا؟
هل العالم أقرب إلى الحرب أو لا؟
....